welcome back to special report joining
me live in studio former FBI director
James Comey little tougher to get across
town without a motorcade oh it's tough
for everybody Jay I understand you have
a new book out I've heard that yeah
thanks for being here the book is higher
loyalty truth lies and leadership big
sales in its first week I've read the
book I've seen or read every interview
that you've done on this media tour a
lot of people have focused on President
Trump and your interactions I want to
get to that but I want to start
chronologically with Hillary Clinton
email probe and the decisions you made
there is it true that you and your FBI
colleagues made the decision to
exonerate Secretary Clinton well before
she was interviewed no so why wait till
the end and why write up the the memo
that you eventually bring forward yeah
first that's a good question come May
after we've been doing it for about ten
months I started to as part of my
regular briefing from the investigators
see that their view was it was unlikely
to end in a case that the prosecutors at
DOJ would bring before the interview
sure yeah because they'd spent ten
months digging around reading all her
emails putting everything together
interviewing everybody who set up her
system
they weren't certain of that result but
they said look boss on the current
course and speed it looks like it's not
gonna get to a place where the
prosecutors will bring it so then in May
I started thinking okay if it continues
that way and it may not but if it
continues that way so how do we end this
thing in a credible way but what if
anything could she have said in that
interview that would have changed your
mind and somehow changed what you
eventually decided to do well two ways
first by lying in a way that we could
prove in the interview or or giving us a
hook to continue the investigation to
see if we could prove a lie or admitting
something that would surprise us about
her intent now a lot of folks have asked
good question about why to do the
interview at the end that's fairly
typical for a subject interview in a
white-collar investigation I think you
see the special counsel Muller taking
exactly that approach with the president
but you already knew that she had been
telling whatever you want to say lies
myths truths about this investigation
and what and how she handled those
emails tickle ism
Secretary Clinton said there was nothing
marked classified on her emails either
sent or received was that true that's
not true Secretary Clinton said I did
not email any classified material to
anyone on my email there is no
classified material was that true there
was classified material email Secretary
Clinton said all work-related emails
were returned to the State Department
was that true no we found work-related
emails thousands that were not returned
so we went on I mean they were clearly a
pattern there and you had already made
your decision no I had not made my
decision but I could see what the
investigators saw after ten months if
you don't have a general sense of where
you're headed after ten months of that
kind of work you're not competent they
could see it was unlikely although I'm
not certain unlikely to get us to a
place where they would prosecute it at
the Justice Department and the question
was would she lie to us what people say
in the public forum in a debate during a
you know political campaign is not our
business our businesses are you gonna
lie to us and if you are and we can
prove it then we're gonna prosecute you
go back to intent a lot but actually the
statute as it's written handling
classified information grossly negligent
doesn't deal with intent
well grossly negligent is an expression
of a kind of intent what how were you
acting what was your mental state at the
time you were careful to call it
extremely careless not grossly negligent
right I was struggling with the fact
that we thought it was not mere
sloppiness but didn't rise the level of
criminal misconduct at the Justice
Department prosecute so how do you
describe that I probably should have
said really sloppy but I wanted to be
honest and say it's above sloppy it
doesn't add up to what the 1917 statute
meant when it said grossly negligent is
a felony so why did you allow Cheryl
Mills Secretary Clinton's chief of staff
to sit in on that interview she was a
potentially a subject or a target in the
investigation she was a government
employee she wasn't Clinton's attorney
but yes she sits in there and talks with
her throughout the interview yeah my my
understanding was at that time she was
one of Clinton's attorneys she was no
longer subject in our investigation the
agents had scrubbed her conduct very
carefully by that point and she was no
longer a subject but that again that's a
reasonable question but the facts are
not a subject one of Clinton's lawyers
she's entitled to be in an interview we
asked people to tweet in or write in we
have one from J Harper Wilson I am a
retired FBI agent serving almost 25
years retire in 1995 as a senior
executive special agent please ask
Thursday why a grand jury was not used
in the Hillary Clinton investigation as
would be normally and why was it run out
of HQ book did not address yeah the
second one I'll take first it was run
out of HQ because it was a case of
intense interest outside to the media
and so to keep it tight it was worked in
the counterintelligence division at
headquarters you can reasonably disagree
with that if you're an FBI person could
have put it in Washington field office
could have put it in New York but the
decision that counterintelligence made
was it'll be kept tighter and leak proof
which it was in the counterintelligence
division and no grand jury I'm not
allowed to comment on the way in which
the grand jury was used I can say this
though she was not interviewed in front
of a grand jury which is another
judgment call that prosecutors and
investigators make all the time you
thought Attorney General Loretta Lynch
was compromised that you had to do
something different because that tarmac
meeting with former President Clinton
and because she had wanted to call it a
matter correct yeah and other things in
this classified thing that ends up
leaking to the New York Times but she
denies this she writes if he had any
concerns regarding the email
investigation classified or not he had
ample opportunities to raise them with
me both privately and in meetings he
never did so someone's not telling the
truth here is it the former attorney
general are you no actually I think
we're both telling the truth I never
went to her and said Loretta I think you
should recuse yourself my problem was
she had already announced it publicly
that she wouldn't and that she would
accept my recommendation and so at that
point what do I do and I decide at that
point I got a step away from her
all right fast forward a lot of people
are upset about how it comes out how you
take control it actually leads to rod
Rosenstein he cites this in what you did
as a reason for recommending your firing
you go on after that recommendation you
write a letter to Congress to announce
the cases reopened because more
classified emails have been found on
Anthony Weiner's computer you said it
was last night a tough choice between
concealing or coming forward a really
tough choice but there are authorities
in New York who were saying that 8th FBI
HQ was slow-walking
that case
and weeks went by without any action did
you know that Andrew McCabe your deputy
had sat on that revelation about the
emails yeah I don't know that I don't
know that to be the case I do know that
New York and FBI headquarters became
aware that there may be some connection
between weiners laptop and the Clinton
investigation weeks before it was
brought to me for decision and as I
write in the book I don't know whether
they could have moved faster and why the
delay so was it the threat that the New
York agents were gonna leak that it
existed really what drove you to the not
concealed part I don't think so I think
actually what drove it was the
prosecutors in New York who were working
the criminal case against Weiner called
down to headquarters and said are we
getting a search warrant or not for this
that caused I'm sorry Justice Department
headquarters to then call across the
street to the FBI and poke the
organization and they started to move
much more quickly I don't know why there
was if there was slow activity why it
was slow for those first couple weeks we
move on to the Trump investigation we're
told after this Australian diplomat
reports his conversation with George
papadopolis talking about plans to get
Russia info or emails about Hillary
Clinton that the FBI is notified through
the State Department about this in early
May true know when were they notified
there's like I'm not confirming what the
source was from it the FBI learned the
information about Papadopoulos in late
July and opened a counterintelligence
investigation at that point
the meeting that you're talking about
occurred in the spring April before
there were any public revelation of
Russian hacked emails but the FBI didn't
learn about it until late July okay so
what is the crime or the collusion that
launches the investigation the occlusion
is not a word that I'm from what is the
what is the evidence basically the
question is you open a
counterintelligence investigation to
understand are any Americans in cahoots
with the foreign intelligence activities
of an adversary nation when the steal
dossier comes out sometime early July
when did you personally learn about the
memos in the dossier sometime in the
fall I don't remember exactly when
you're talking fall of fall sorry fall
of 16 right so who told you about them I
don't remember someone on my senior
staff you read how they were described I
remember they briefed me about it
explain that it came from a reliable
source former Allied intelligence
officer I remember being given a copy of
it I don't know where there was
September October sometime in that
period of time when did you learn that
the DNC and Hillary Clinton campaign had
funded Christopher Steele's work yeah I
still don't know that for a fact
what do you mean I've only seen it in
the media I never knew exactly which
Democrats had funded and it was funded
first by Republicans Appaloosa I'm sorry
that's not sure that the dossier that
Christopher Steele worked on was funded
by Republicans my understanding was his
work started funded by Oppo Riaz Oppo
research funded by Republicans free
beacon and said that they had Glenn
Simpson infusion GPS on a kind of a
retainer but they did not fund the
Christopher Steele memo or the dossier
that was initiated by Democrats okay my
understanding was the activity was begun
that the steel was hired to look into
was first funded by Republicans then
picked up the important thing was picked
up by Democrats opposed to Donald Trump
so is that why did you tell President
Obama that the dossier was ever who was
funded by no not to my recollection you
want to know who was funded by I wanted
to know what I knew which is it was
funded by people politically opposed to
Donald Trump okay which particular
opponents wasn't that important when did
you say you still to this day don't know
that it was funded by the DNC media but
I don't know for a fact and didn't know
why was that the FBI who which exact
opponent of the president's funded that
okay how many times did you and to what
extent did you briefed President Obama
on the test yet I didn't ever briefed
President Obama on the dossier I was
present during a conversation where
Director of National Intelligence
briefed it to him as we did to the gang
of eight and to the president-elect the
first week of January called the dossier
unverified salacious
why did you use that to define a court
to ask for surveillance for Carter page
not only use it but you led with it a
bulk of that FISA application deals with
that dossier why yeah that's not my
recollection Brett and I don't know that
the FISA application has been released
my recollection was it was part of a
broader mosaic of facts
were laid before the FISA judge to
obtain a FISA warrant it was a lot more
than the dossier in the FISA application
my recollection was there was a
significant amount of additional
material about page and why there was
probable cause to believe he was an
agent of a foreign power and the dossier
was part of that but was not all of it
or a critical part of it was my
recollection this Intel briefing at
Trump Tower you briefed the
president-elect on kind of a sliver of
the dossier that really that salacious
part about the prostitutes in Moscow and
that allegation right didn't include
anything broader than that right correct
my my my mission in that private
briefing was just to tell him about that
slice of it and he suggested you brief
that I think the Director of National
Intelligence did and explain the logic
of why it made sense for me to do it
which I agreed with so that briefing was
just oral it was just talking to the
press just the two of us talking to a
CNN reporter at the time that you handed
a two page executive summary of the
dossier over to him I did not did not
speaking of CNN you write in the memos
of that meeting you write I said to
president-elect romp media like CNN had
the dossier and we're looking for a news
hook I said it was inflammatory stuff so
the story of that briefing leaks out
almost immediately after you do at CNN
and others run the story of this
unverified dossier did did you or your
subordinates leak that no did James
clapper no not to my knowledge no John
Brennan I I don't know who leaked it I
had no part in any leaking of it it was
about four or five days later that it
leaked but I remember cuz President
Elect called me about it you ever try to
find out who leaked an unclassified
public document no did you inform the
president-elect at the time what you
knew about how it was funded of who was
behind it no I do not did you inform him
that Christopher Steele had been fired
by the FBI no or that he had lied no and
I didn't know those things at that time
anyway where that had been used at least
in part to to get this fire application
to spy on somebody in his campaign
didn't come up is it fair to say the
President Obama in his other page was in
his campaign without order was a private
little gently at one point okay is it
fair to say the President Obama in his
under circle knew a lot more about the
dossier and the scope of the
investigation than president-elect Trump
and his team no I don't think that's
you think that they were equal on as far
as the briefing far as I know they knew
they knew the same set of facts as did
the leaders of Congress there was no
difference between what the FBI told the
FISA Court and what the Trump about the
Trump Russian investigation and what you
told the new President United States
what the FBI and the FISA application
said in October of 2016
I don't remember clearly enough all
that's in the FISA application but we
sure didn't lay that out for anybody
president obama president like trump or
the leaders of Congress okay a lot of
questions about the interactions with
President Trump and your memos
memorializing that after you're fired on
Capitol Hill we learn this 17
by asked a friend of mine to share the
content of the memo with a reporter
didn't do it myself for a variety of
reasons by asked him to because I
thought that might prompt the
appointment of a special counsel and so
I asked a close friend of mine to do it
who was that a good friend of mine who's
a professor at Columbia Law School so
what specifically did you leak to mr.
Richmond I sent mr. Richmond a copy of a
two-page unclassified memo and asked him
to get the substance of it out to the
media you call him a good friend and a
professor but you didn't reveal that you
had hired him as a special government
employee for the FBI to work on special
projects why because it wasn't relevant
he was FBI special government employee
until February of 2000 and did you have
seven special advisers like that no so
what exactly was his job to thanks
his primary focus was on our going dark
challenge helping us think through and
articulate and fight for access to
encrypted communications and in law
enforcement data was a big part of his
responses so did you leak other things
through mr. Richmond yeah okay others
I'm smiling bread is I don't consider
what I did with mr. Richmond a leak I
told him about an unclassified
conversation with the president I gave
him nothing else ever okay to share with
them FBI protocol says your own
employment agreement with the FBI
prohibits quote the unauthorized
disclosure of any information or
material from or related to FBI files or
any information acquired by virtue of my
official employment without prior
written permission from the FBI did you
have written permission no and I didn't
consider it part of an FBI file all the
things I talked about with it as an FBI
director he was a work product no it was
not it was my personal aide memoire
president sure I created two copies of
it one to keep him my personal safe at
home and I left another with the FBI so
the bureau could always have access to
it but I always thought of it as mine
like a diary who else did you give leek
Hill or whatever you want to call it it
was - yeah - I gave the memos to my
legal team after I gave him to Dan
Richmond after I asked him to get it out
to
Media and if they re give four memos to
my legal team which included Patrick
Fitzgerald Patrick Fitzgerald is a legal
team at that time correct sure and David
Kelly Kelly and Dan rich okay you said
in the memos I said I don't do sneaky
things I don't leak I don't do weasel
moves but I mean we can argue what a
leak is but that's illegal isn't it it's
not okay here's what you told chuck
grassley about leaking director Comey
have you ever been an anonymous source
in those reports about matters relating
to the Trump investigation or the
Clinton investigation never has any
classified information relating to
President Trump or his associations
associates been deep classified or and
shared with the media not to my
knowledge
so at what point were you made aware
that some of the information was
classified by the FBI which ever
mentioned in the memos oh yeah
I don't know sometime after I was fired
the FBI apparently made a decision that
there were some words and at least two
of the memos maybe one I think two that
were diplomatically sensitive and so my
lawyers returned them to the FBI but
that testimony was truthful and I stand
by it
I was hoping you were gonna ask me that
I am I was I want to play what the
president said today about you on this
channel
look Comey is a leaker and he's a liar
and not only on this stuff he's been
leaking for years he's probably been
using his friend the so called professor
who now turns out to have FBI at
clearance which he never said he even
lied about that because he never said
that in Congress he said he gave it to a
friend and he gave it to a friend to
leaked classified information it's all
classified it was totally classified so
here illegally he did an illegal act and
he said it himself in order to get a
special counsel against me
action to that he's just wrong facts
really do matter which is why I'm on the
show to answer your questions that memo
was unclassified then it's still on
classified it's in my book the FBI
cleared that book before it could be
published that's a false statement what
about not telling Congress that he was a
agent for you or I worked at the FBI or
somehow was some employee that you had
35,000 that was true I describe to my
hope in a good way as a good friend to
expose there might be a bias in my
connection to the guy he had left his
FBI job months earlier and so there's
lots of other connectors I know him
because we were prosecutors together I
didn't mention that I taught with him a
Columbia didn't mention that I think I
offered the Congress a fair picture of
my connection to the guy